se faire vacciner aborde un vaporetto et
admirer la lagune de venise est
désormais possible
l'un de ces bateaux a été transformée en
centre de vaccination flottant pour
permettre aux résidents des îles sans
terrassement et vigneault les de
recevoir leur première injection
ce matin nous sommes à 100 terrasse moss
pour célébrer le lundi de pâques le jour
suivant la résurrection avec nos
personnes âgées de plus de 80 ans qui
vont sur cette île qui vont se faire
vacciner selon un mode très particulier
nous sommes sur un vaporetto équipés à
cet effet pour pouvoir vacciner les
personnes âgées
ce sont les services de santé de la
région vénétie qui ne laisse personne de
côté
nous sommes ici ce matin pour démontrer
que les services de santé sont un bien
commun et nous les apportons là où ils
seront nécessaires les deux il ne
dispose pas de centres de vaccination et
les déplacements peuvent être compliqué
pour les personnes âgées
c'est pourquoi la municipalité offre
cette possibilité aux habitants très
convaincu par cette initiative un coin
isolé est aménagé à bord du bateau les
autres patients attendent leur tour sur
la rive
cette initiative est génial car ils vous
vaccine si vous avez pris un rendez vous
j'ai été le premier à en avoir un et là
je me sens plutôt bien
selon les rapports des autorités locales
ce dimanche le vaporetto à transporter
200 doses de vaccin de nombreux sites
publics sont également utilisés pour
mener à bien la campagne de vaccination
ailleurs en italie avec de nombreuses
régions classées en rouge le pays a
maintenues ces restrictions pour le
week-end de pâques et aucune procession
n'a eu lieu
les restrictions mises en place le 15
mars dernier ont même été prolongée
jusqu'au 30 avril